as fun as it is to watch a great movie
there's no guarantee that you'll walk
out of the theater feeling good yourself
here are a few fantastic flicks where
the last few minutes are so monumentally
depressing that they're almost
guaranteed to wring a few tears from the
audience if you only saw the last three
minutes of end of watch you might think
this cop drama was ending on a happy
note the final scene features two
buddies having a laugh over a crazy
story on what looks like a pretty good
day unfortunately context is everything
in actuality the camaraderie between
officers Brian Taylor and Mike Zavala is
an incredibly bittersweet flashback
scene one that jumps back to a moment
before Zavala was gunned down by
gangsters Taylor and Zavala are super
cops in fact they're such good cops that
they try to take down the Sinaloa cartel
only that doesn't pan out too well after
disrupting the cartels business
the officers are ambushed by heavily
armed thugs and despite their bravery
Taylor is gravely injured and Zavala is
murdered after learning about his
partner's death
Taylor is absolutely shattered Zavala
was his best friend in the world and at
the funeral Taylor is so grief-stricken
that he can only muster four powerful
words that make all those happy moments
heartbreaking he was my brother
Thanos first appeared in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe all the way back in
2012 but when he finally arrived on
earth with the Infinity Gauntlet
Earth's Mightiest Heroes were completely
overmatched with a single snap of his
fingers Thanos wiped out half the
population of the universe including the
majority of our beloved heroes Black
Panther Doctor Strange and even poor
teen group went up in smoke the most
painful death to watch though was Peter
Parker's
I don't feel so good even though he just
fought the toughest villain in the MCU
Parker's still just a kid afraid of
fading away avengers endgame will
undoubtedly undo a lot of the damage but
when a horrified Captain America the
team's strongest and most optimistic
member is this wrecked you know things
have gone bad infinity war might have
the darkest ending of any major
blockbuster ever there's no moral
victory here there's no feel-good speech
for the first time ever the Avengers
have truly lost and it all ends with
Thanos admiring his handiwork smiling as
the Sun rises on a grateful universe
despite their godlike superpowers the
Avengers are a sad bunch of people and
the most tragic might just be Steve
Rogers a man out of time in Captain
America the First Avenger the
star-spangled superhero decides to
sacrifice his life crashing a hydroplane
into the Arctic ice in those final
moments before taking the plunge cap
promises to take his new love Peggy
Carter dancing as soon as he returns
obviously neither expect Steve to make
it back home but well you've seen movies
I understood that reference when Kap
finally returns he learns that he's been
asleep for nearly seven decades it's a
gut punch of a moment and the look of
shock and sadness on CAPS face is
heartbreaking yeah he survived the
suicide mission but the world he knew is
gone and he's been separated from the
woman he loves for most of a century
when fury finally asks if cap is going
to be okay all his pain is summed up in
one sentence yeah
yeah I just
[Music]
I had a date war movies aren't really
known for their upbeat endings but when
it comes to pure tear-jerking power
nothing goes after your heartstrings
like 1989's glory this Civil War flick
tells the story of the 54th
Massachusetts infantry which was the
first African American regiment to fight
for the Union Army the regiment was led
by Colonel Robert Shaw played in the
film by Matthew Broderick and after
overcoming all the racism you'd expect
from the 1860s Shaw and the 54th wind up
leading the charge in the film's
climactic battle unfortunately that
battle doesn't go their way after being
surrounded by Confederate soldiers Shaw
charges the enemy hoping to inspire his
men and he's quickly gunned down
enraged private Silas trip a role that
earned Denzel Washington an Academy
Award picks up the flag and charges
after the colonel only to be shot down
seconds later their sacrifice inspires
the rest of the 54th to rush out of the
ravine and continue their charge but
despite their bravery the historic
soldiers are no match for cannonballs
and all the characters we've come to
love played by the likes of Morgan
Freeman Cary Elwes and Andre Braugher
are blown to oblivion if that wasn't sad
enough the movie ends with Shaw's and
trips bodies being buried side by side
in a mass grave Gone Baby Gone isn't
exactly a feel-good film to begin with
and the ending is appropriately downbeat
based on the novel by Dennis Lehane this
thriller follows to Boston detectives
Patrick Kenzie and Angie Gennaro who are
hired to find a little girl named Amanda
at first they believe this kid was
murdered by a local drug dealer but as
they dig deeper into the case they
discover a surprising conspiracy as it
turns out Amanda's concerned uncle
kidnapped her from her abusive addict
mother with the help of several
high-ranking cops but Patrick isn't a
big believer in moral ambiguity and
brings a conspiracy down and has the
little girl sent back home they might
not regret it when you get home you may
not regret it for a year but when you
get to where I am I promise you you will
sure enough it doesn't take long for
regret to set in when Patrick goes to
visit Amanda he sees that her mom is
just as awful as ever and realizes he
might have damned Amanda to a life of
poverty neglect and mistreatment in the
final moments he volunteers the
babysit Amanda and sits beside her
watching the traumatized lonely girl as
she stares at the television it might
seem weird to say this about a movie
where a gorilla fights a helicopter but
Rise of the Planet of the Apes has more
than its fair share of emotional moments
nothing can top the finale when Caesar
happily played by mocap master Andy
Serkis says goodbye to his human friend
will Rodman their relationship is the
emotional crux of the story caesar is
known will his entire life and the
biologist is basically his adoptive dad
in fact will is the guy who gave caesar
his above-average intelligence but after
will is forced to put caesar in a
primate sanctuary the chimpanzee decides
it's time for a revolution after
sparking a full-blown primate rebellion
and a battle on the Golden Gate Bridge
Caesar and his army disappear into a
redwood forest but before vanishing into
the trees Caesar is confronted by will
who begs the chimp to come back home
that's when Caesar pulls his foster
father close and whispers in his ear
with those three powerful words Caesar
and will realize nothing will ever be
the same
Tom Hanks movies generally leave
audiences feeling pretty good but road
to perdition is a bloody exception to
that cheerful rule this gangster flick
finds Hanks playing Michael Sullivan
senior a mob enforcer out for revenge
while trying to make sure his surviving
son Michael jr. doesn't wind up dead too
that's easier said than done when you're
being hunted by a psychopathic hitman
for a moment it seems like everything
might be okay then Michael's violent
past catches up with him when he's
ambushed by the assassin after taking
two bullets in the back
Michael lies dying as the psychopathic
hitman assembles an old-timey camera and
begins taking photos of his bloody
victim Michael jr. shows up with a gun
to interrupt the Hitman sick hobby but
unlike his dad the boy isn't a killer
fortunately the distraction gives his
father enough time to gun down the
assassin before shuffling off this
mortal coil
what really seals the deal in queues the
sobbing though is Michael Jr's final
lines answering the question of whether
his father was a good man I always give
the same answer I just tell them
he was my father directed by Martin
Scorsese shutter island' is a
frightening film noir that binds
Leonardo DiCaprio as Teddy Daniels a
detective who's investigating the
disappearance on an Alcatraz style
mental hospital but as Teddy and his
partner dig deeper into the case Teddy
makes a horrible discovery he isn't
really Teddy in reality he's Andrew
ladis a world war two vet who killed his
mentally ill wife after she murdered
their kids his partner is actually his
psychologist and the whole investigation
is an elaborate role-playing game meant
to bring Andrew back to reality and if
the game doesn't work then poor Andrew
has to get lobotomized after this
shocking twist it seems that Andrew
reverts back to his Teddy persona or
seen his doctors to perform the lobotomy
but before he's taken away to his
mind-numbing fate Teddy looks over at
Chuck and asks a haunting question which
wouldn't be worse the live is a monster
when a die is a good man it's a simple
line but it conveys the crushing sadness
of Andrews story the experiment worked
Andrew knows exactly who he is and what
he's done it's his guilt that leads him
to accept his grisly fate Arnold
Schwarzenegger movies aren't generally
considered tearjerkers but the ending of
Terminator 2 Judgment Day has caused so
many sobs from macho movie fans that
it's basically the action movie
equivalent of The Notebook you think
come on emotional don't you I can be
emotional Jesus I cried like a child at
the end of tonight at 2:00 sent from the
future to protect teenage John Connor
the t800 starts out this sci-fi flick is
an ice-cold killer robot as he spends
time with the future resistance leader
however the t800 becomes the teens best
friend and father figure growing
increasingly lovable as he battles with
a shape-shifting Android he's picking up
slang words developing human emotions
and learning you can't just go around
killing people
he also realizes that if humanity is
going to survive then all terminators
need to be destroyed after defeating the
t1000 Arnold realizes that if he doesn't
destroy the advanced AI inside his own
head that tech will eventually give rise
to the robot rebellion that will doom
mankind so despite John's pleas for him
to stay the t800 slow
he lowers himself into a pit of molten
steel he gives a thumbs up before
disintegrating completely letting John
know everything is going to be ok but
despite that reassurance poor John is in
tears and so is everybody watching the
saddest ending in Swartz a [ __ ]
career I know know why you cry
but it's something I can never do with
movies like requiem for a dream in his
filmography it's safe to say that Darren
Aronofsky loves a truly depressing
ending but of all the films he's ever
directed none have caused as much
sobbing as the wrestler this gritty and
grim drama follows the story of Randy
the RAM Robinson a professional wrestler
who's far from his in-ring glory days
this dude has lived a hard life and made
some bad decisions and now he's all
alone
his daughter doesn't want anything to do
with him his romantic life isn't working
out and the world outside the ring is
nothing but pain and misery lonely and
depressed Randy gets back into the
wrestling game where at least the fans
respect and adore him but stepping back
into the ring comes at a high price
Randy has a bad heart and knows that
another match might be his last however
when he hears the cheers of the crowd
the wrestler climbs up onto the
turnbuckle to perform his signature move
even as his heart starts to fail him
when he leaps down on to his opponents
we know it's the last time he'll ever do
the legendary Ram Jam but it's all worth
it for Randy because he's living and
dying for the only family he's ever
known the fans who now have to watch
their hero die in the ring in front of
them check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stopper coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you